what do you think about Andrew Tate I
think his views are horrendous but I
don't hate him because hate would
require me to give him energy and I'm
not giving them any of my energy your
time I'm glad that he's off social media
and that he's been banned on most times
of course you are you could take one
look at somebody and figure out what
they think about entertaining forms what
are one of the views that you disagree
with just like what he thinks about
women that women are his property and
that like women have to do whatever
their husband says like that's a big no
no for me bro what are you talking about
man he just talks about leaving the
Matrix taking personal responsibility
going to the gym just self-improvement
what do you think about that from what
it sounds like he's perhaps telling men
that they have to fight through their
feelings and I feel like that's not the
way to approach things I think men are
supposed to so what the [ __ ] do you know
about men just genuinely does Andrew
have a better idea of how men should
leave their life or this guy to be
vulnerable and should be vulnerable and
can be emotional and any kind of like
toxic masculinity where you're telling
men to fight through all of that is not
okay can you define toxic masculinity
here we go malfunction ready yeah